hey welcome back it's shea and emily and
we're here with the third tutorial of
the app inventor hour of code hey emily
i challenge you to a quick draw you're
on
okay that was childish but surprisingly
fun yeah
it's time for our next app and we just
gave you a preview
it's going to be a great app for this
app we're going to make a drawing canvas
on the board where you can use your
finger as a pen
we call it digital doodle okay back to
the drawing board
get it drawing board
right here we go once again log on to
app inventor if you're not already there
start a new project
name this one digital doodle
just like in the ball bounce app you'll
need a canvas to start but before we do
that do you remember the trick we
learned for keeping the app from
scrolling
right go into the properties for screen
1 and uncheck scrollable
now add a canvas which you can find
under drawing and animation
go to the properties pane of the canvas
and change the settings for both width
and height to fill parent that opens up
our canvas quite a bit also
even though we're not going to use it
just yet
drag out an accelerometer component from
the sensor drawer and drop that into
your app
time to program the blocks
okay so the event that will detect
someone's finger dragging on the canvas
is pretty easy to guess
click on the canvas components blocks
and look around in the drawer
can you figure out which block you need
right you want the event handler for
when canvas 1 is dragged this event
handler has a whole bunch of parameters
don't worry they're pretty easy to
understand
and you can get on-screen help anytime
just by mousing over a block like this
okay great so we want to draw a line
from wherever the finger drag was last
to where it is now
we'll essentially make the canvas draw
hundreds of tiny lines between the
points of the finger drag
this will look just like drawing on the
phone's screen
but first we need the block that will
draw a line go to canvas one again
and this time get the block that says to
call canvas1.drawline
now we need the x and y coordinates of
the beginning of the line draw to the
end
the when dragged event will call draw
line over and over while the finger is
dragging on the screen
we just need to provide the x y
coordinates for these lines
go ahead and use previous x and previous
y
you'll also need current x and current y
now go try out your app
it should let you draw on the screen
this app is great but wouldn't it be
cool if you could shake to erase a
screen rather than press a button yeah
like etch-a-sketch okay it's at your
sketch time
remember we put an accelerometer sensor
into the components list
so now we can program that
go to the accelerometer drawer and pull
out when shaking the block we need to
erase the screen is really simple to get
go to canvas and choose call
canvas1.clear
plug that purple block right into the
event handler for shaking
great test your app again does your
drawing erase when you shake it all
right
so once again we've built a very simple
app which can be extended in lots of fun
ways the app that we demonstrated at the
beginning of this tutorial
lets you take a picture first and then
put the picture on the canvas where you
can draw on it
you could also set up buttons to change
the color of the ink used in the drawing
all of these extensions are explained in
the paint pick tutorial on our website
as you can see there are endless
possibilities of what you can build with
app inventor it taps into almost all of
the phone's capabilities you can even
send and receive texts and phone calls
if you have a fully functional phone
even on a tablet over wi-fi you can do
some pretty cool things thanks for
joining us if you're interested in
learning more about app inventor go to
the app inventor website
happy inventing